bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir et
pénaliste avec un grand P la lionne du
barreau on frémit déjà et on a hâte de
vous entendre Clarisse serre la lionne
du barreau c'est le titre de votre
témoignage chez Sonatine où va en parler
une femme qui fait du pénal dans le 9-3
ça n'est pas banal ça n'est pas fréquent
on est ensemble pendant une heure pour
décrypter l'actualité de ce mardi 17
janvier au sommaire ce soir les
retraites à deux jours du bras de fer
dans la rue gros plan ce soir sur le
chômage des seniors comment ramener les
seniors vers l'emploi c'est l'un des
objectifs de la réforme le gouvernement
planche sur un index qui ne convainc pas
pour pour l'instant les syndicats alors
travailler plus longtemps oui mais
comment si nos aînés sont au chômage
c'est notre grand débat dans un instant
et puis aux alentours de 20h15 vos
rendez-vous avec les parties pris de nos
affranchis et le bourdon Express
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée voilà
pour le menu ce soir vous savez tout
clarifaire on y va ça vous regarde c'est
parti
[Musique]
au boulot jusqu'à 64 ans à condition à
condition de pouvoir la France est
quasiment la championne du chômage des
seniors en Europe plus d'un pardon plus
d'un plus de 55 ans sur deux est au
chômage alors inciter les entreprises à
garder ses aînés c'est l'un des
objectifs de de cette réforme oui mais
comment précisément et avec quelle
chance de résultat bonsoir Louis
Marguerite et merci d'être là vous êtes
député renaissance de Saône-et-Loire en
face de vous Sébastien Jumel bonsoir
ravi de vous retrouver député communiste
de scène maritimes bonsoir Hubert
Delaunay et merci d'être là vous avez 57
57 ans vous êtes passé par une période
de chômage vous allez nous raconter et
puis cette expérience finalement
difficile vous a convaincu et bien de
créer votre propre entreprise c'est une
plateforme experte zone ça s'est passé
il y a deux ans vous allez nous
expliquer ça vous aider aujourd'hui les
seniors à retrouver un emploi enfin
bonsoir Franck Boissin merci d'être là
vous représenter les entreprises sur ce
plateau ce soir spécialiste dans le
recrutement directeur général de
Serendip cabinet de recrutement dans les
métiers de la santé Clarisse serre cette
entre cette réforme évidemment des
retraites elle concerne tous les
citoyens vous et moi donc vous pouvez
intervenir quand vous le souhaitez ces
affaires de chômage des seniors ça se
termine parfois devant les tribunaux
donc n'hésitez pas on a besoin
évidemment pour commencer ce débat de
planter le décor j'appelle mon camarade
et ami Stéphane blackovski le tour de la
question en 200 secondes c'est le chrono
de Blacko tout de suite
garder notre cher Stéphane du haut de
son estrade alors si j'ai bien compris
le chômage des seniors
mais on en prend juste pour dire bonsoir
On est pas bon on est mauvais dans ce
domaine à la traîne même en Europe en
fait il y a deux manières de voir les
choses sur cette question de l'emploi
des seigneurs d'une certaine manière ça
serait même un sujet sur lequel on
pourrait pousser un petit cocorico pour
être fier regardez on a fait des progrès
considérables dans ce domaine par
rapport à l'année 2010 vous voyez le
taux d'emploi des seniors a augmenté de
quasiment 15% en France donc on pourrait
être fier de ça profitons de ce petit
moment de fierté parce qu'en fait dès
qu'on se compare alors là il y a plus du
tout de quoi être fier notamment par
rapport aux autres pays occidentaux vous
voyez notre taux d'emploi nous classe
parmi pas tout à fait les derniers mais
quasiment les derniers alors ça constaté
que l'économie française est dernière
c'est un truc Bruno Le Maire il veut pas
le supporter Guy Bruno Demers il a été
premier de la classe toute sa vie donc
il va pas non plus commencer à être dans
la position du cancre on l'écoute en
disant que c'est révoltant
c'est une perte de compétences c'est un
gâchis d'expériences c'est un gâchis
d'humanité c'est un gâchis collectif
il est pas content il n'est pas content
alors pourquoi on en est là vous allez
pouvoir débattre vous n'êtes pas
forcément d'accord mais de ce que je lis
aujourd'hui on va dire que on a sans
doute trop longtemps cru en France en
fait que si on mettait les vieux plutôt
en dehors de l'entreprise ça ferait de
la place pour les jeunes qu'on pourrait
les embaucher et en fait bah non pas
vraiment regardez tout le chômage des
jeunes en France bah là aussi on est
parmi les derniers donc il y a pas
vraiment de vases communicants entre
les 10 situations il y avait François
Hollande qui avait une idée en 2013 je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez de
contrat de génération régler les deux
problèmes d'un coup on aide les
entreprises qui embauchent des jeunes à
condition qu'elle ne vire pas les
seniors et donc d'ailleurs certains
syndicats disent bah oui ce n'est pas
une mauvaise idée on devrait faire ça
parce que belle idée la solidarité entre
génération gouvernement lui est moins
enthousiaste ne serait-ce que parce que
en 2016 la Cour des comptes a fait un
rapport en disant que cette histoire de
contrat de génération c'était un flop
total donc forcément on a supprimé ça en
2017 donc aujourd'hui le gouvernement
eux pour leur méthode qui consisterait à
améliorer le taux d'emploi des seniors
tout simplement c'est la des retraites
c'est à dire que si on recule l'âge de
la retraite mécaniquement on va
augmenter le nombre de personnes un peu
plus âgées qui resteront dans les
entreprises il y a quand même un petit
problème quand on dit mécaniquement un
grain de sable qui pourrait bloquer
cette mécanique c'est cette spécificité
française auxquelles le monde consacré
un article l'an dernier le fait que en
France les entreprises ont tendance à se
débarrasser de leur Seigneur quand elles
le peuvent et le monde n'est pas le seul
à le dire la première ministre ne dit
pas autre chose on l'écoute
quand on voit des entreprises souvent
des grandes entreprises qui font des
plantes départ volontaires ou des
ruptures conventionnelles collectives
ciblées sur les seniors c'est un signal
un très mauvais signal qu'on est en
train de donner au seniors qu'on
voudrait les voir partir bon alors là on
a carrément montré les grandes
entreprises du doigt donc que faire
j'imagine qu'on va essayer de les
convaincre un peu par la force leur
mettre la pression donc c'est ce qui est
prévu dans la réforme qui serait une
sorte d'index des seniors pas une sorte
d'ailleurs c'est le nom qu'on lui donne
l'idée donc c'est de déclarer pour les
entreprises depuis 300 salariés leur
statistiques sur l'emploi des seniors et
puis c'est tout si elle ne montre pas
leur statistique là éventuellement elle
pourrait être punie donc vous imaginez
bien qu'il y a des balles là-dessus ne
serait-ce que sur cette question de
l'index ou les syndicats disent même
enfin s'il y a pas du tout assez
contraignant et le Medef du contraire
mon dieu c'est beaucoup tôt contraignant
merci de matière radeba et ben le décor
est planté comme chaque soir merci
Stéphane pour ce pour ce billet Paris
tenue pour le chrono et tout et tout
aussi informé on va parler de l'index
dans un instant mais on va déjà vous
entendre sur le diagnostic qu'est-ce qui
marche pas vous marquez d'abord les
chiffres ont été rappelés on a
effectivement le taux d'emploi du
seniors le plus faible d'Europe alors
pour une raison c'est qu'on a le taux
d'entrée de départ à la retraite le plus
le plus bas et d'ailleurs y compris avec
la réforme que nous proposons et que
nous souhaitons voter au Parlement on
restera quand même dans des taux dans
des taux d'entrée les plus faibles
d'ailleurs de départ franchement
ministre et Bruno Le Maire long évoqué
et d'ailleurs si on s'intéresse là on
parle de la tranche 55 64 en fait il y a
un taux d'emploi qui est beaucoup plus
faible sur 60 64 ans et effectivement il
s'est évoqué par la première ministre un
certain nombre de grandes entreprises et
d'ailleurs parfois encouragé par les
pouvoirs publics les 15 20 dernières
années qui encourager les plans de
départ de volontaires les pré-retraite
etc et on voit bien 59 60 c'est à dire
un certain nombre d'entreprises donc
c'est plutôt les entreprises qui
poussent vers la sortie statistiquement
on peut le dire
il faut faire strictement l'inverse
justement et j'imagine qu'on va revenir
sur sont les mesures que nous proposons
il faut encourager justement la retraite
progressive qui est l'esprit inverse de
ce qui se passait jusqu'à présent c'est
à dire de pouvoir bénéficier d'une
petite partie de sa retraite tout en
continuant à cotiser d'ailleurs pour
augmenter absolument mais tout en
restant dans l'entreprise et c'est
totalement l'esprit inverse ça permet
d'augmenter au niveau des pensées des
solutions je voudrais vraiment
comprendre ce qui se passe dans notre
pays c'est bastien jumelles c'est un
problème auquel a été confronté aussi
bien la droite que la gauche et c'est
franchement l'échec à chaque fois
personne n'arrive attendre le coup au
chômage des seniors pourquoi
les marcheurs la droite le gouvernement
ne fout pas la démonstration que le
recul de l'âge de la retraite aura un
effet mécanique sur l'employabilité des
seniors pourquoi cela
parce que les freins
dans le retour à l'emploi des seigneurs
sont multiples lesquels
précisément géographique nous avons des
statistiques qui démontent que en milieu
rural dans des bassins de vie moins
dynamiques le retour à l'emploi et moins
simple et puis parce que le mécanisme
qui a conduit à ce que dans les
charrettes de licenciement les seniors
soient
en plus grand nombre était justifiés par
le fait que des entreprises se
débarrassaient d'une main d'oeuvre
d'anticonsidérée qu'elle était trop
chère les salaires sont souvent plus
élevés lorsqu'on a de l'ancienneté et
considéré que les seigneurs avaient une
productivité moindre et ce qui
justifiait y compris dans les plans
collectifs de licenciement
j'allais dire les myriades de Seigneur
c'est à dire que la question de l'emploi
du seigneurs est une question sérieuse
mais elle
pas de mon point de vue d'accepter la
mauvaise réforme qui nous est présentée
parce que cette se concentrer sur ce
thème là on connaît la position de la
gauche
travailler plus tard oui réfléchissons à
l'emploi des seniors travailler plus
tard pour ce qui nous concerne c'est non
indépendamment de ça travaillons à
l'emploi des seniors et des freins sont
multiples le positionnement géographique
les dynamiques de formation la confiance
en soi qui est érodée d'ailleurs quand
on est jeté comme un kleenex dans un
plan de licenciement et puis la réalité
des corps alors vous l'avez dit la
réalité des corps les corps usés les
j'allais dire des esprits abîmés et et
dégradés y compris en termes de
confiance qui sont des freins colossaux
dans le retour je vais vous proposer
avant de vous donner la parole de les
entendre ces seniors qui restent sur le
carreau alors certains y croient encore
beaucoup font des CV des centaines sans
réponse souvent donc entre découragement
et parfois désarroi avant de vous donner
la parole messieurs reportage de Léo ce
et de Benoît Ducros
devant cette agence parisienne de Pôle
Emploi le constat est sans appel plus on
vieilli plus il est difficile de
retrouver du travail à un peu plus de 61
ans Catherine en est la première témoin
parce que il ne voyait plus comme des
jeunes mais la dernière fois que j'ai
été dans une boulangerie on m'a dit oui
bah vous savez on va pas vous garder
parce que c'est pas parce que vous êtes
âgés mais comme vous vous êtes lentes
voilà je marchais pas assez vite dans la
boutique je pourrai pas assez vite et
avec la réforme des retraites elle va
devoir travailler encore un peu plus
comme je suis né en octobre 61 je vais
devoir travailler trois mois de plus
j'ai déjà du mal à trouver du travail là
maintenant alors je sais pas comment ça
va être dans trois mois non ça c'est sûr
une situation compliquée qui n'épargne
pas les plus diplômés et les cadres
Alexandra petit signe de l'association
pour l'emploi des cadres en ces quelque
chose elle anime des ateliers
voilà exactement c'est dans cette salle
que on organise donc ces animations à
destination de ces cadres éloignés de
l'emploi le principal objectif c'est
déjà donc de pouvoir et bien échanger
sur leurs freins et sur leur perception
en fait de la situation de Senior j'ai
l'exemple en tête d'un d'un cadre
dirigeant donc dans la finance qui avait
des difficultés en fait à valoriser
ses compétences sur tous les outils
digitaux et le fait de s'entraîner à en
parler bien ça lui a permis vraiment de
réussir son entretien
accompagné par une autre association aux
et 75 Jérôme et rulin 60 ans continue de
traquer les offres d'emploi alors je
continue à me demander candidats vous
voyez il y avait hier est arrivé dans
les listes des offres que LinkedIn m'a
envoyé un poste de directeur de la
communication groupe je suis convaincu
que mon endroit où je n'ai pas à Muriel
mieux c'est effectivement dans une
équipe de direction d'une boîte en
prenant en charge à la stratégie de
communication mais faute de réponse
favorables pour l'instant il a dû
changer de stratégie il souhaite
désormais développer une activité de
consultant j'ai un peu fait mon deuil
d'avoir un poste en CDI c'est-à-dire un
poste permanent dans une équipe je veux
aider des équipes et les intégrer à la
demande donc c'est ce qu'on appelle un
travail de consultant monter sa propre
structure peut-être une solution pour
rester actif
voilà devenir son propre patron quand
plus personne ne veut vous embaucher ça
vous parle évidemment ça Hubert Delaunay
racontez-nous un peu ce qui s'est passé
pour pour vous créer sa boîte parce que
personne ne veut de vous c'est ça moi je
me suis retrouvé deux fois dans la
position du senior sans emploi la
première fois j'avais 45 ans 45 ans on a
l'impression qu'on est passé Niort si si
on est seniors dans le monde du travail
je parle pour les cadres en tout cas
c'est la partie que je connais bien
c'est un choc qui est assez difficile
il y a une forme de pertes de soi c'est
une claque de soi il y a la perception
qu'on sait rien faire en fait qu'on n'a
pas de compétences on sait on est sorti
de son entreprise on commence à envoyer
des CV on n'a pas de retour ou alors des
45 ans on a on n'a pas de retour donc il
y a une vraie perte de confiance en soi
et c'est ça que j'ai beaucoup aimé dans
le dans l'intervention vous venez de
montrer c'est le le des associations
comme
osé ou comme actes il y en a plusieurs
ou comme l'Apec qui accompagne et je
pense que pour des seniors qui perdent
leur emploi la première chose à faire
c'est de se faire accompagner vous avez
au fond
profil type en termes de statistiques ce
sont ce sont pas forcément les cadres
sup qui sont touchés par ça
ce sont des employés ce sont les
ouvriers toutes les catégories
socio-professionnelles sont concernées
tout le monde est concerné par le par la
peur d'emploi par certains nages et la
difficulté à retrouver un poste c'est
pour ça que nous à partir de la deuxième
expérience de perdre d'emploi avait
rebondissant sur mes expériences j'ai
créé ma plateforme qui permet au seniors
de de de d'essayer de retrouver un
emploi de figure précis c'est
l'employeur qui vous a dit merci au
revoir ou on entend aussi parmi les
cadres voilà j'arrive à la retraite au
fond je négocie un départ c'est ce qu'on
appelle une rupture conventionnelle pour
être au chômage un an et puis ensuite
toucher
le un matin on vous dit bah c'est
terminé alors c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça mais c'est comme ça que
ça se passe et puis il y a tous ces
cadres qui pensent vers vers l'âge que
j'ai aujourd'hui mais c'est pas ce qui
m'est arrivé
l'arrache de la frette et non pas très
longtemps on va me proposer un chèque
finalement je vais bien retrouver un peu
d'activité et je vais tenir jusqu'à mes
62 65
64 voilà ça va être 64 64 c'est le
minimum après on verra le 19
quand on a commencé à travailler à 25
ans pour ce qu'on fait des études ce
sera pas 64 ce sera 67 68 70 ans il faut
en avoir conscience il y a quand même
c'est 67 exactement et ce que j'ai bien
aimé l'intervention c'est la personne
qui se prend en main c'est-à-dire quand
on est cadre et c'est probablement
beaucoup plus facile que quand elle
était employée ou ouvriers dans une
usine on peut créer sa structure et
proposer ses services un poste de
directeur de la communication ils sont
tous pris il faut pas se leurrer les
postes directeur de la communication
dans les entreprises ils sont pris donc
la seule manière de se repositionner
c'est de se dire comment je peux
proposer mes services et aller voir les
entreprises qui ont peut-être pas
directement les députés les politiques
dire au fond il y a que l'histoire de
l'âge légal qui fait que mécaniquement
l'entreprise va garder son senior ça
vous suscite quels commentaire ça va
être très bien les seniors avec un index
les seniors vont rester un peu plus
longtemps en entreprise mécaniquement ça
va ça va faire retarder l'âge
probablement mais ça va pas résoudre le
problème de ceux qui n'ont plus d'emploi
ou ceux qui qui dont l'entreprise a fait
faillite et qui se retrouvent sans rien
les entreprises qui fonctionnent bien
elles vont garder leur Seigneur un peu
plus longtemps ça fera partie de leur
politique RSE ça va être ça va être bien
enrobé et ça va être utile à mon avis en
revanche ça ne résout pas la
problématique de ceux qui n'ont pas
d'emploi ou de ceux dont les entreprises
on fait faillite ou ne peuvent ne
peuvent pas recruter il faut regarder
les les les deux axes en fait et
aujourd'hui à mon avis il faut regarder
travailler sur l'employabilité donc sur
la capacité à trouver un emploi ou
trouver un travail rémunéré sortant des
cadres standards pour toutes ces
personnes qui n'ont pas d'emploi
aujourd'hui alors j'ai regardé je me
tourner vers vers vous Franck Boissin
c'est l'entreprise est-ce que est-ce que
pour vous c'est le principal responsable
l'acteur économique de ces chiffres là
arriver cinq ans parfois 45
voilà on est poussé vers la sortie
oui c'est l'entreprise c'est différente
partie quand un mécanisme fonctionne pas
d'ailleurs mon jour présente pas les
entreprises je suis le témoin des
entreprises puisque elles font
travailler elles nous donnent des
cahiers des charges pour les remplir et
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui on observe
plusieurs freins à l'employabilité des
seniors en France
qui sont pas les mêmes francs en
Allemagne même si comparaison n'est pas
raison on a vu les chiffres ici les
freins principaux freins sont d'abord
les problèmes de trésorerie quand
certains entreprises on se rappelle
qu'on est en période post covid et que
certains ont commencé à rembourser les
PGE d'accord et donc évidemment
elles ont souvent
de se débarrasser d'un seigneur
débarrasser moi je parle d'employabilité
moi je travaille sur l'emploi je
travaille pas sur les plans de les plans
de sortie les plans de départ
volontaires comme l'a monté la première
ministre moi je travaille sur des
cahiers des charges on me dit il
faudrait recruter telle personne donc là
on a un prélève de trésorerie ça
coûterait plus cher d'employer donc
d'embaucher quand on doit rembourser des
prêts ce sujet sur lequel on doit
apporter notre conseil on doit apporter
de la pédagogie j'espère qu'on y
reviendra on est au Palais Bourbon on
essaye de réguler par la loi mais il y a
aussi la pédagogie des différents
acteurs que sont les seigneurs dans
l'emploi que sont les seigneurs sans
emploi ce sont les managers les
dirigeants et les instances régaliennes
de l'entreprise il faut aussi qu'il faut
aussi éduquer on se rappelle quand même
que la discrimination à l'emploi existe
dans ce pays les lois existent et que
aujourd'hui c'est pas toujours respecté
sur le sur notamment les seniors il y a
une discrimination à l'emploi des
seniors en France
et pourquoi ces pierres chez nous si
vous on comprend les freins mais c'est
quoi c'est aussi une question de culture
est-ce qu'il y a un rapport au travail
qui est différent on a identifié
différents points je vous ai parlé de la
rémunération pour les problèmes
trésorerie il y a un autre point
important qui est le changement du
gouvernance des grandes entreprises qui
ont une complexité très forte et
notamment avec ce qu'on appelle les
matricielle vous avez plusieurs bosses
plusieurs managers et autres et ça crée
de la complexité donc ça c'est un
changement que les jeunes générations
plus de capacité à embrasser
c'est-à-dire quoi vous vous avez pas une
tâche complète mais elle est découpée
c'est ça vous participez à une tâche
collective
plus horizontale et c'est plus complexe
et sinon la nation qui se met en place
depuis une vingtaine d'années qui est
plus compliqué appréhender pour
certaines personnes ça c'est le Seigneur
qui a pas la bonne culture
avec un niveau d'anglais qui en France
c'est simple les jeunes de 18 à 24 ans
revendique parlait l'anglais à 60% et
les plus de 60 ans revendiquent le
parler à 18%
les expertises sont intéressantes un
cadre qui montre sa boîte un conseiller
en réinsertion professionnelle pour les
cadres très bien mais il y a une réalité
d'abord une réalité sociale 495
000 retraités cumulent des retraites de
misère avec des emplois de misère est-ce
que c'est un projet de société qu'on
veut dans la sixième puissance mondiale
pour nos seigneurs et pour les habitants
d'une manière générale deuxième réalité
dans les freins de retour à l'emploi
quelle est la nature des emplois
proposés au Seigneur la proportion des
CDD ou des emplois précaires et massives
deuxièmement l'éloignement géographique
des bouleaux proposés c'est à dire que
vous êtes seniors vous avez construit
votre vie y compris en termes
d'habitation et on vous propose un
boulot avec un salaire évidemment
considérablement réduit souvent lorsque
vous êtes en ville moyenne ou en milieu
rural à des dizaines et des dizaines
kilomètres de chez vous et donc la
question de du temps de parcours pour
aller au boulot du salaire proposé de la
nature de l'emploi proposé est un
obstacle évidemment de réinsertion
professionnelle et puis enfin moi
j'insiste beaucoup là-dessus
je viens de là alors il y a des cadres
il y a les professions intellectuelles
et peut-être on rêve tous les uns et les
autres d'être en situation de
productivité le plus longtemps possible
mais ce qu'on des boulots manuels les
chaudronniers soudeur chez moi les
verriers au bouchots les salariés d'une
fonderie chez moi qui s'appelle Sival à
eux et dont on a organisé pas plus pas
plus tard qu'hier un job dancing pour
faire en sorte qu'ils trouvent du boulot
et ben cela je vous assure que je
pourrais citer les aides-soignantes les
aides à domicile ou même les infirmières
de nuit à 58 ans ils sont flingués ils
sont usés et compris le frein de retour
à l'emploi réside dans leur capacités
physiques à retrouver sur la pénibilité
et donc moi je suis convaincu et
d'ailleurs des des projections il y a
une hypocrisie des de la majorité
là-dessus nous démontre que en reculant
l'âge de départ à la retraite on
multiplie par 4 le nombre de seigneurs
au RSA on augmente le taux de chômage
des seniors et qui nous est proposé
enfin c'est du pipeau
sur l'effet pervers de l'allongement
l'âge de départ notamment pour les plus
fragiles pour les plus modestes pour
ceux qui sont cassés comme disent
Sébastien jumelles ça va mettre encore
plus de seniors au chômage qu'est-ce que
vous répondez pas obligé de nous traiter
d'hypocrite parce que j'allais dire
qu'on était d'accord au moins sur un sur
un constat qui effectivement d'abord il
y a une grande diversité de situations
et vous avez raison on parlait de cas
peut-être plutôt de grandes entreprises
avec des nouvelles organisations on a le
cas effectivement d'organisation plus
petites ou effectivement de métiers plus
j'aurais pas dû dire hypocrite je
m'excuse je conserve vous mentais sur
toutes les arguments sur tous les
arguments voilà c'est bon
pour répondre à votre collègue dans
l'opposition en effet en effet il y a il
faut savoir que le taux de chômage des
seniors il est plutôt plus faible que la
moyenne en revanche une fois que vous
êtes au chômage vous avez des la
probabilité que vous retrouvez en emploi
et plus et beaucoup moins élevé
absolument en France donc là là dessus
il y a un sujet c'est les chiffres donc
là dessus il y a un sujet c'est
effectivement tous les sujets de
reconversion effectivement on n'est pas
du tout allait en France parce qu'il
faut être extrêmement accompagné ça a
été dit par vous monsieur c'est les
questions d'accompagnement quand vous
regardez le chiffre ils sont terribles
on a à peu près 30% seulement
des plus de 60 ans dans le pays
seulement absolument donc là-dessus
d'abord c'est une expérience terrible
quel que soit son niveau de
qualification qu'on soit cadre capsule
ou évrier ou vrille qualifié ou pas
qualifié peu importe il faut les
accompagnements là-dessus il faut qu'on
qu'on donne un coup de boost sur toutes
les structures d'accompagnement il y a
celle de Pôle emploi il y a toutes les
associations il y a sans doute des gens
qui ne les connaissent pas il y a un
point parce que je veux pas revenir ce
que qu'évoque monsieur jumelles c'est la
question de la mobilité elle est plus
difficile lorsque vous êtes un certain
âge déjà il est pas elle est pas très
développé dans le dans notre pays parce
que pourtant tout un tas de raisons
parce qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de mobilité
du travail à l'inverse d'ailleurs de
l'Allemagne ou des États-Unis donc les
reconversion
travailler ailleurs en milieu rural
comme métropole si vous avez raison donc
du coup là dessus il faut mettre le
paquet sur les cons sur tout ce qu'on
est sur les congés de reconversion c'est
ce qu'on a fait dans le C2P donc le
compte de professionnels de prévention
qui va permettre du coup d'acquérir un
centre de points ça existe déjà et là on
le val on va augmenter les critères on
va permettre d'améliorer de façon à ce
que un un seigneur on va le qualifier
comme ça puisse à un moment donné avec
des points qu'il est acquis prendre un
congé de formation et de reconversion
dans des métiers sans doutement et
d'être un peu plus sur mesure que tout
ce qui existe déjà
comment vous réagissez à ce débat
d'abord profession libérale au moins on
est son propre patron moi j'en connais
des avocats on n'est pas à la retraite à
65 ans après toi sont remplis de temple
grises oui alors pour l'instant les de
ce que j'ai compris on est pas enfin
pour l'instant puisque c'était pas le
cas dans le passé mais là on est épargné
dans notre régime moi ce qui me marque
surtout c'est que cette nouvelle réforme
face à cette pourquoi elle est annoncé
maintenant avec tout ce que les Français
ont subi est-ce que c'était le bon
timing de l'annoncer des janvier avec
tout ce qui s'est passé
psychologiquement j'avoue que il y a eu
la covid que tout le monde a vécu
difficilement on a à la guerre en
Ukraine enfin il y a beaucoup de soucis
est-ce que c'était vraiment le bon
moment c'est la première question que je
vous pose à tous et puis la deuxième
question c'est vraiment le choc des
cultures c'est à dire que on a du mal à
comprendre pourquoi autant de questions
se posent c'est-à-dire que je pense que
tout le monde finalement est d'accord
pour dire qu'il faut réformer les
retraites c'est tout le monde est
d'accord mais pourquoi on n'arrive pas à
trouver un consensus pourquoi on
n'arrive pas à comprendre la pénibilité
comme vous l'avez rappelé pour certains
et puis d'autres aussi pour les cadres
c'est vrai que de mon point de vue il y
a quelque chose assez extraordinaire
c'est que quand on est profession
libérale et c'est valable d'ailleurs
aussi bien pour les avocats que par
exemple pour les médecins ou pour
d'autres professions libérales plus on
vieillit plus on acquiert une
reconnaissance professionnelle et je ne
vois pas je le dis vraiment le plus
sincèrement possible et les salariés
vous envie d'une salade
surtout mais je n'arrive pas à
comprendre pourquoi la maturité que l'on
peut avoir en vieillissant n'est pas
connu pour les pour les cadres et n'est
pas reconnu pour une autre forme pour la
pénibilité et j'avoue ne pas ne pas
comprendre pourquoi ces aspects parce
que avant de dire qu'il va y avoir
encore des projets d'accompagnement je
crois que surtout que les questions qui
se posent c'est de savoir pourquoi les
Français n'arrivent pas à comprendre ce
qu'on est en train de nous proposer
aujourd'hui allez Louis Marguerite je
vous propose de répondre parce que c'est
vrai que ces questions voilà la
citoyenne
des maîtres serres vous vous les
adresses directement d'abord j'entends
la question légitime plusieurs personnes
ont demandé mais est-ce que c'était le
bon timing je
sais pas si c'est le bon timing en tout
cas pour une fois difficile en tout cas
que ça percute quand même avec des
difficultés des Français evidemment
évidemment moi je tombe dans ma dans ma
circonscription me parle de premier
énergie on me parle des difficultés à
recruter notamment pour les dirigeants
de TPE de PME etc qui ont du mal à
trouver donc on a évidemment toutes ces
difficultés le sujet c'est que je suis
pas sûr qu'un bon timing pour faire une
réforme dans lequel on va demander aux
Français à certains Français de
travailler un peu plus d'ailleurs pour
partie pour financer les d'autres
mesures sur lesquelles d'ailleurs les
syndicats sont d'accord avec nous à
l'issue du processus de discussion qui a
eu donc je suis pas sûr moi je noterai
jusqu'à un sujet c'est que il y a au
fond pour préserver notre système auquel
on est tous attaché trois grandes trois
grandes options soit on baisse les
pensions mais je pense que personne
autour de plateau sera partant pour le
faire et justement on veut faire plutôt
l'inverse s'augmenter les cotisations on
a eu ce débat là c'est une question de
coût du travail soit il travaille bien
on commence à connaître les éléments de
langage
on s'est pris le covid en pleine face
deux ans ça a bousculé les vies et ça a
bousculé les vit tout court on a
l'uppercut de l'inflation avec la crise
de l'énergie qui y compris fragilise
l'économie réelle on a à 2000 km de chez
nous les bombes en Ukraine qui sont
anxiogène pour la population
on aurait dû dans ce moment de crise
sans précédent travailler à réconcilier
la République avec elle-même travailler
à apaiser la République le choix de
l'itinéraire d'un enfant gâté le
président de la République c'est de
fractionner d'opposer et de cliver et
donc c'est évidemment pas opportun en
termes de temps et pas importants se
feront leur propre opinion ce débat il
est évidemment extrêmement clean on va
revenir quand même au chômage des
seigneurs s'attendait sur lequel planche
le gouvernement il n'est pas dans le
texte financier sur les retraites il y
aura un autre projet de loi pour le pour
le mettre en œuvre en attendant est-ce
que ça peut marcher convaincu le patron
de la CFDT Laurent Berger écoutez
sur cet emploi des seniors il y a un
index nous on l'a pas demandé l'index en
tout cas il y a une mesure de l'employé
senior ça va mesurer quelque chose qu'on
connaît c'est les entreprises dans leur
grande majorité elles licencie les
seniors ou elle les font partir parce
que elle trouve moins productifs ou trop
cher et quand on aura mesuré si
l'entreprise joue pas le jeu il se
passera rien voilà oui Marguerite pour
ceux qui nous regardent est-ce que vous
pouvez expliquer le dispositif très
clairement on va noter les entreprises
en fonction d'indice d'emploi des
seniors c'est ça et qu'est-ce qui va se
passer après pour répondre à Laurent
Berger d'abord moi je note quand même
que beaucoup disent ça sert à rien parce
que c'est pas contraignant bon d'abord
je note quand même que le patronat était
opposé à cette mesure donc ça prouve que
ça va quand même leur demander un effort
sans doute pour pour une raison simple
c'est qu'en fait ils vont devoir
afficher effectivement les seniors après
il y aura peut-être des des nuances ce
sera publié sur les documents le rapport
annuels
c'est important pour les journalistes de
pouvoir regarder en public grand public
cette information certes c'est peut-être
pas contraignant j'entends le point
alors d'abord il
[Musique]
n'est pas suffisant pour pour l'égalité
salariale homme-femme ça a plutôt marché
on voit que les entreprises jouent le
jeu comment vous vous le recruteur vous
vous regardez cette index
moi j'ai plusieurs opinions là-dessus la
première c'est que la diversité
aujourd'hui n'inclut pas la seniorité et
vous avez raison on inclus le genre on
inclut la couleur de peau on a pas mal
de communication de l'entreprise
là-dessus sur les personnes à mobilité
réduite en revanche on n'a pas de
seniors sur les photos et en fait sur
les campagnes de communication intra
extra-entrepreneurs
qui n'existe pas donc il faut absolument
venir là-dessus revenir en pédagogie sur
les entreprises en explication et on a
réussi et quand même on a montré tout à
l'heure dans l'intervention qu'on avait
progressé sur l'employabilité des
seniors donc c'est pas fait en claquant
des doigts donc c'est intéressant et
l'index
moi je me méfie les index parce que tout
simplement on se rappelle que la
contribution de la langue qui était au
début des années 2000
les années 2000 si un employeur
licencien personne de 50 ans il était il
avait quelque part une amende à 55 ans
une autre amende et moi je vivais
qu'autant entreprises à cette époque là
j'étais un jeune manager et j'ai vécu
quand même il faudra les sortir avant la
contribution de la lande donc quand on
va mettre de l'index qu'est-ce qui va se
passer on sait très vite que tout ce qui
est sanctions contraintes les
entreprises n'aiment pas et si on
mettait des quotas pour terminer les
quotas de seniors
je ne sais pas où mon collègue a sorti
l'idée pour l'instant d'une pénabi d'une
pénalité puisqu'on ne connaît ni le
seuil qui enclenche 300 salariés pour
les entreprises
les plus de 1000 salariés seront
concernés l'année suivante les plus les
les 300 mais on ne connaît pas le seuil
de déclenchement de l'amende dont on
parle l'index il est donc inopérant
parce qu'on a la photographie de la
réalité du sort réservé à l'emploi des
seigneurs et donc ce qu'il faut c'est
agir sur les questions de formation ce
qu'il faut c'est agir sur les questions
de mobilité ce qu'il faut c'est agir sur
des questions d'accompagnement de de de
de d'accompagnement pour une réinsertion
professionnelle y compris pour regagner
confiance en soi et puis ce qu'il faut
c'est ne jamais oublier je termine par
là que le temps de la retraite c'est
aussi un temps d'utilité sociale 50% des
élus locaux sont des seniors 40% des
dirigeants associatifs sont des seniors
et l'utilité y compris la valeur ajoutée
économique de cet engagement et citoyen
il est nié par ce qui porte la réforme
on va s'arrêter là merci merci beaucoup
évidemment il y a énormément de choses à
dire et énormément de tiroirs dans cette
réforme on va les ouvrir un à un dans
cette émission le feuilleton des
retraites se poursuit bien sûr sur LCP
merci messieurs vous restez avec moi
Clarisse serre dans une dizaine de
minutes les partis pris de nos
affranchis vous les voyez ils sont déjà
prêts en coulisses le choix de 20 ans
ujeux grand porteur Vincent du jeu ce
soir c'est le voyage de Marine Le Pen en
Afrique la carte blanche numérique de
Delphine s'abatier sur la face cachée du
chat dit ce robot prodigieux qui
inquiète aussi et puis Bourbon express
avec Stéphanie Despierre qui va nous
parler de la CGT en tout cas une partie
de la CGT qui menace les élus en tout
cas ce qui sont pro réforme des
retraites à tout à l'heure les amis mais
d'abord car il sert on va parler de vous
on va parler de ce livre la lionne du
Parrot qui êtes-vous pourquoi le pénal
et pourquoi Bobigny on voit ça dans ce
portrait signer Marco Polo
si on vous invite Clarisse serre c'est
parce que vous attisez notre curiosité
vous l'avocate pénaliste surnommé par
vos confrères la lionne du barreau
référence à votre chevelure à votre
pugnacité aussi aujourd'hui vous prenez
la plume pour raconter votre parcours et
le sens de votre engagement clairement
jour Clarisse c'est une star de sa
profession Clarisse vous êtes La Serena
Williams les avocats la Céline Dion des
tribunaux la Marie-Pierre Casey des
parquets clarissèrent vous êtes sur tout
l'une des rares femmes à s'être imposées
dans la caste des pénalistes
l'aristocratie du barreau ou les robes
noires sont généralement celles des
ténors jeune vous vous imaginiez avocate
de la veuve et l'orphelin et pourtant
votre clientèle rassemble surtout des
bandits sulfureux trafiquant drogue
assassin agresseur sexuel et autres
délinquants financiers vous réfutez le
terme de clients et préférez le mot de
patient parmi les plus célèbres l'un des
neveux de la fratrie Hornec ou encore
vert Zenatti accusé de complicité dans
la spectaculaire évasion d'Antonio
Ferrara moi je n'ai pas d'a priori pour
défendre l'un ou l'autre moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de défendre votre
trajectoire est atypique inhabituel
quand vos confrères préfèrent le confort
des cabinets parisiens vous vous imposez
un challenge traversez le périphérique
pour installer votre cabinet à Bobigny
vous détenez et comme une provocation
vous écrivez je suis une femme je fais
du pénal j'exerce dans le 9 3 et alors
et des cours d'assise au plateau de
tournage il n'y a qu'un pas conseillère
technique pour la série à succès
engrenages votre parcours inspire vous
êtes même l'héroïne d'une nouvelle série
66,5 l'histoire d'une jeune avocate
pénaliste qui tend les beaux quartiers
parisiens pour plaider en
Seine-Saint-Denis au secours des voyous
bref vous ne vous arrêtez jamais c'est
ce qui fait le chant de notre métier
après 27 ans de métiers justement vous
témoignez à vivre aujourd'hui sur les
conditions de travail difficiles des
magistrats sur votre difficulté aussi à
passer les portes des prisons alors
clarisseur vous la pénalise au
convictions si fortes hostile
anticonformiste avec le sens de la
justice chevillée au corps une question
nous tarotte ce soir arrive-t-il à la
lionne du barreau de douter
réponse clarisseur vous la lionne du
barreau si coriace et si libre ça vous
arrive aussi de douter c'est pas que ça
m'arrive je doute en permanence c'est
d'ailleurs pour rebondir précédent
débats que vous aviez sur la retraite je
me faisais la réflexion le seul avantage
que je vois dans ce métier au bout de 27
ans c'est que plus on vieillit plus on
gagne en maturité et qu'on pourrait
penser peut-être il y aurait une forme
de sérénité et il y a pas cette forme de
sérénité puisque je pense que si je ne
doutais pas tous les jours et bien je
pense que je serai là c'est de ce métier
je pense que je ne serai plus à même de
bien exercer mon métier vous dites
plaider me met dans un état de transe
mais c'est aussi une souffrance on les
laisse des plumes
porter la vie d'un homme ça n'est pas
facile il y a beaucoup de pression nous
sommes associés au diable et parfois je
me demande pourquoi je fais ça oui j'ai
voulu écrire ce livre parce que j'avais
envie non pas de découragé des jeunes
avocats parce que bien au contraire il
faut absolument dans un pays
démocratique c'est très très important
pour moi qui la défense pénale existé et
qu'elle soit vraiment sont représentés
aussi bien par des hommes que par des
femmes mais c'est aussi un métier que
l'on porte dans sa chair on peut pas le
soir quand je rentre tard chez moi je ne
laisse pas ma robe dans un coin et je
passe à autre chose non ça nous habite
en permanence et donc oui on doute oui
c'est un métier qui est pesant mais
c'est aussi ce qui fait
ce qui fait sa force voilà
vous avez la défense pénale vous êtes
pénaliste exactement la même chose les
assises notamment que un avocat
spécialisé je sais pas moi en droit du
travail
cette passion cheville au corps de la
défense elle vient d'où j'ai
l'impression qu'elle vient depuis
l'enfance j'ai vraiment si un jour je
devais un jour m'allonger sur un divan
c'est certainement la réflexion j'ai un
souvenir d'enfance où j'ai vu une
injustice l'adolescent j'en ai aussi
croisé un certain nombre d'injustice et
puis j'ai toujours eu envie de défendre
je crois qu'il faut surtout faire
comprendre aux gens parce que souvent
c'est une question qu'on me pose mais
est-ce qu'on peut défendre
l'indéfendable et c'est d'expliquer aux
gens que tout le monde a le droit à une
défense qu'il faut essayer dans la
mesure du possible de de ne pas
s'arrêter aux apparences parce que quand
on voit des faits divers on vous dit
voilà c'est c'est horrible ce qui s'est
passé on est tous d'accord pour dire ça
et moi j'ai la chance de côtoyer
beaucoup de gens des gens qui sont
libres des gens qui sont en prison et
plus je les côtoie plus je me dis quand
même que il faut connaître l'humain
alors vous avez une clientèle qui est
quand même souvent composé de voyous par
un de la drogue clan Hornec les membres
du Cercle vague vous dites moi je sors
les types de la mouise il y a pas de
fascination quand même pour s'améliorer
là du tout non faut pas avoir de
fascination pour ce milieu là parce que
justement ce qu'il faut quand on est
avocat c'est mettre la séparation entre
ce que l'on défend et le métier que l'on
fait quand on exerce ce métier vous
savez au tout début le premier jour du
reste de notre vie professionnelle c'est
le jour où on prête le serment d'avocat
et les qualités qu'on requier d’un
avocat c'est notamment l'indépendance et
c'est vraiment important pour moi de
dire que l'on peut défendre toute
personne les gens pensent souvent qu'il
y a une fascination non moi ce que je
dis souvent c'est que j'aime beaucoup
les polars je participe notamment et
vous le savez à certaines séries de
télévision et de cinéma et moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est jusqu'au côté le côté
fiction maintenant quand j'exerce ma
profession je suis intéressé par les
dossiers que je lis mais je n'ai pas de
Fas pour ceux que je défends oui alors
c'est un livre qui est autant un
témoignage une déclaration d'amour à
votre vocation à votre métier mais c'est
aussi un livre sur l'envers du décor
vous voulez susciter des vocations mais
vous voulez aussi dire la vérité parce
que c'est un milieu dur il faut
s'accrocher résister il y a énormément
de pression je vais vous montrer deux
images
regardez
vive du pénal ça va pas de soi vous êtes
passé du 27 boulevard Saint-Michel on va
voir c'est à deux passer à gauche
du Luxembourg magnifique Luxembourg vous
travaillez au très prestigieux cabinet
de pierre-alique et Jacqueline Laffont
pour hélas c'est en face du tribunal de
Bobigny le 21 rue de l'indépendance
c'est un autre monde qu'est-ce qui vous
a fait basculer pourquoi vous avez
choisi et bien ce deuxième monde alors
moi déjà je viens je viens de changer de
je suis toujours à Bobigny mais je viens
de changer récemment au mois d'août de
bois d'août dernier d'adresse mais
toujours à Bobigny juste derrière le
commissariat donc je suis d'un côté j'ai
le commissariat puis pas loin j'ai le
palais de justice j'ai envie de vous
dire d'abord vous voyez les photos
évidemment le jardin du Luxembourg ça
fait rêver mais d'autres aussi rêvent
sur le pas le palais de Bobigny vraiment
c'est années 70 ça fait référence à
Beaubourg également il y a des gens qui
aiment Beaubourg il y a des gens qui
n'aiment pas bobo donc ça c'est la
peinture
je pense aussi que moi je vois l'avenir
et l'avenir pour moi il s'est construit
par un passé qui a commencé 27 boulevard
Saint-Michel et qui se poursuit parce
que je pense que j'ai été quelque part
un peu visionnaire quand j'ai quitté
Paris il y a 10 ans de ça maintenant en
me disant qu'un jour et bien Bobigny ça
ferait partie du Grand Paris les choses
semble-t-il les événements me montrent
raison il y a le Grand Paris il y a les
Jeux Olympiques vous savez pour les Jeux
Olympiques la plupart des événements
vont se passer où dans le 93 je pense
que le 93 c'est pas uniquement réduit à
la délinquance réduit à du négatif c'est
aussi une un vivier de jeunes qui ont
envie de montrer autre chose c'est aussi
j'appartiens à ce barreau de Bobigny qui
est l'essence même de la défense pénale
pour moi alors je pense même de la
défense pénale c'est un énorme tribunal
c'est vraiment
judiciaire du France
sous les difficultés vous écrivez que
les magistrats qui travaillent apportent
leur stylo et même leurs ordinateurs
alors c'est tout à fait exact mais
justement à force je suis pas la seule
heureusement mais à force de le dire et
bien le ministre de la Justice a
d'ailleurs annoncé un budget une
augmentation considérable et j'espère en
tous les cas que le un des premiers
tribunaux de France qui va en partie qui
va en bénéficier ces Bobigny mais
Bobigny a une caractéristique absolument
incroyable et d'ailleurs je vous invite
à venir parce que l'apparence
effectivement peut en effrayer certains
mais je vous invite à venir assister une
audience je vous invite à aller voir ce
tribunal tient par la conviction des
magistrats qu'il compose par les
greffiers qui le composent par les
fonctionnaires de police qui le
composent et également évidemment une
source très importante ce sont les
avocats c'est la deuxième juridiction de
France et ce tribunal tient aussi grâce
à ça
les relations avec les magistrats
est-ce que sont par nature avocat
magistrats difficile et compliqué ou
c'est plus compliqué
on est formé on fait la même on fait les
mêmes études on fait des deux droits
mais après on a chacun des points de vue
différents maintenant aujourd'hui je
crois qu'il faut passer au-delà des
contentieux que l'on peut avoir avec les
magistrats la situation est suffisamment
grave pour la justice en France pour
qu'il faut que l'on comprenne que on ne
peut pas travailler sans magistrat et on
ne peut pas vivre dans un pays
démocratique sans avocat il faut qu'on
dépasse ce qui peut nous opposer pour
aujourd'hui surtout c'est que la justice
devienne une priorité nationale et que
les Justiciers se disent on a compris ce
que la justice j'entends trop
régulièrement régulièrement je suis
invitée et régulièrement des gens me
téléphonent où on voit des messages en
disant moi je le comprends pas cette
décision je ne comprends pas pourquoi la
justice est si longue je ne parle même
pas du réflexe qu'on me dirait
généralement c'est de dire la justice et
laxiste moi qui suis quasiment tous les
jours dans tous les tribunaux de France
la justice n'est pas laxiste donc je
pense surtout ce qui est important c'est
de réconcilier citoyens avec la justice
alors vous êtes pénaliste avec un grand
pays il y a pas de mots pour dire
pénaliste ténor tu es Nora soprano on
cherche des mots vous vous voulez
pénaliste et vous y tenez j'y tiens
beaucoup avec par provocation parfois je
disais allez parlons de diva mais c'est
pour faire avancer des choses je crois
surtout qu'au 21e siècle il est
important c'est pénaliste avec un grand
P vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure le
pénal c'est une un domaine tout à fait
particulier parce que le métier d'avocat
c'est féminisé mais pas beaucoup donc le
vraiment le pénal c'est quelque chose de
très particulier et pénaliste a au moins
un avantage c'est que ça met sur un pied
d'égalité aussi bien mes confrères homme
que mes concerts donc femme et donc
surtout actuellement il y a de plus en
plus d'avocats il y a 60% de la
population de chez les avocats ce sont
des femmes il y a pas encore des
pénalistes il y a peut-être pas autant
de pénalistes femmes que d'hommes mais
elles sont souvent peu connues elles
sont souvent dans l'ombre et elles sont
souvent beaucoup plus effices alors on
va en écouter une très efficace parce
qu'elle a réussi à obtenir la relax d'un
rapport vous la connaissez peut-être
votre
zadourian elle a été la cible de menaces
de mort et de viol sur les réseaux
sociaux après donc cette relaxe de
dasoui pour un vice de procédure dans
une affaire de drogue et de détention
d'armes c'est plus dur pour une femme
pénaliste que pour un homme certainement
été alors moi j'ai pas vécu de
difficultés parce qu'en fait avec du
recul maintenant ce que je me rends
compte c'est que j'ai toujours cru
beaucoup de gens ont essayé de me
dissuader de me dire avocat pénaliste et
pas pour une femme j'ai jamais pensé
comme ça donc je n'ai pas vécu j'ai
toujours essayé de faire au mieux mon
métier donc je n'ai pas vraiment subi de
discrimination dernière question très
rapidement pour terminer Clarisse les
propos qu'elle dit sont très forts et
c'est inadmissible évidemment aucune
menace contre une avocate ou un avocat
n'est acceptable bien sûr il y a
énormément de textes ici sur des
violences faites aux femmes on
raccourcit le délai de prescription
former des magistrats formés des
policiers vous vous dites attention
évidemment ce sont des progrès mais
attention aux dérives du MiTo attention
à ces féministes qui dressent les femmes
contre les hommes
voilà vont questionner voir choqué je
l'assume totalement et je l'ai écrit en
sachant évidemment mais en même temps je
vois que l'écho positif que ça rencontre
parce que on ne parle évidemment des
femmes et encore une fois je le dis je
ne cesserai de le dire c'est violent
sont inacceptables mais malheureusement
j'ai été aussi confronté à des
accusations son fondement des vie
d'hommes détruites et donc c'est
important de dire qu'il faut rétablir un
juste milieu et que vous savez on a
connu on a connu ou trop on avait
sacralisé les paroles des enfants on
s'est on s'est rendu compte avec Outreau
qu'on avait été finalement trop loin
qu'on avait été biaisé par cette parole
des enfants et bien c'est un peu mon
sentiment aujourd'hui c'est ma crainte
que la parole des femmes soit sacralisée
alors qu'elle doit être prise que
l'énergie
et surtout avec un principe essentiel
enfin trois qui sont essentiels à mon
avis la prescription le principe de la
présomption d'innocence et surtout une
preuve ça du barreau c'est chez Sonatine
et si vous vous demandez si vous avez
envie de devenir avocate il faut lire ce
livre absolument vous restez avec moi
Clarisse c'est on passe aux affranchis
on les accueille tout de suite pour leur
parti pris
vincentaire notamment à LCI qui suit du
crâne mais qui va nous parler d'Afrique
ce soir et du voyage de Marine Le Pen au
Sénégal Delphine Sabatier de Bismarck
bonsoir à vous nous parlez du petit
robot prodigieux chatibti dans un
instant mais on commence avec le bourbon
Express comme tous les soirs l'histoire
du jour à l'Assemblée nationale nous est
racontée par Stéphanie Despierres
bonsoir Stéphanie bonsoir et l'histoire
du jour c'est l'histoire d'une petite
phrase très violente celle d'une
déclaration d'un syndicaliste CGT qui a
provoqué la colère des parlementaires de
la majorité et des républicains alors
c'était hier au siège de la CGT avec des
journalistes Sébastien menespié le
secrétaire général de la CGT mines
énergie explique la stratégie du
syndicat pour contrer la réforme des
retraites mais il va plus loin encore il
va jusqu'à menacer les parlementaires
favorables à cette réforme de
représailles alors il dit exactement on
va aller voir ce qu'ils veulent la
réforme qui ancienne et on va s'occuper
d'eux et puis si d'aventure il ne
comprennent pas le monde du travail on
les ciblera dans les coupures qu'on sera
organisée alors ce sont des menaces
c'est à peine croyable à peine croyable
sont des menaces claires face aux
députés menacent à minima de les plonger
dans le noir alors ce matin nous avons
contacté un de ses collègues
syndicalistes à la CGT des mines
énergies comme lui qui nuance un peu
mais juste un peu
on s'interdit rien alors ça passe
effectivement par des coupures mais
certainement pas de la teinte des
personnes c'est des coupures
éventuellement au niveau des des
permanences la menace elle vient pas de
nous quand même faut se le dire au
départ elle vient de ce projet de loi
alors la phrase a fait le tour de tous
les médias depuis hier soir les députés
Renaissance et républicains sont
estomacés il condamne évidemment ses
propos de la CGT
les menaces les intimidations les
tentatives de déstabilisation vis-à-vis
des lieux de la République c'est
absolument inadmissible et inacceptable
et donc j'espère que la personne qui
s'est exprimée s'est exprimé un peu trop
rapidement et qu'elle reviendra
rapidement sur ses propos parce qu'on ne
peut pas tolérer que des députés des
parlementaires des élus des Françaises
et des Français soient menacés intimidés
parce qu'ils portent des projets
politiques parce qu'ils portent des
convictions je trouve que c'est
lamentable d'en arriver à ce genre de
menace j'écoutais ce matin derrière le
représentant sur une chaîne de grande
écoute d'un fonds en continu et je
trouvais qu'il était à la fois arrogant
à la garde d'un député pourtant je
partage pas la même avis que ce député
mais je trouve que ce genre de menace ne
pas sa place dans une république ou
justement la démocratie doit faire loi
alors chez les députés de gauche la
réaction n'est pas tout à fait la même
écoutée
vous cautionnez ces propos ils sont
indépendants libres et responsables dans
leur manière de mener leurs actions j'ai
confiance en eux ce ne sont pas les
modes d'action que feraient la France
insoumise nous nous avons d'autres
répertoires d'action mais je crois qu'il
faut aussi l'analyser comme un signal
d'une colère extrêmement forte
Stéphanie il y avait un autre
syndicaliste Laurent Berger de la CFDT
ici même à l'Assemblée aujourd'hui qui
s'est clairement désolidarisé de ça oui
il était venu parler avec des députés à
de l'opposition du groupe Lyot alors
autant tous les syndicats vous le savez
sont unis pour la mobilisation de jeudi
autant là la CFDT a clairement pris
cette distance avec la CGT
clairement la CFDT est opposée à ce type
de mesure à ce type d'action et donc il
est hors de question de sanctionner
telle ou tel parce qu'il n'aurait un
positionnement on est dans une
démocratie chacun est libre de porter
les idées qu'ils portent nous on veut
faire la démonstration que en mobilisant
massivement les salariés le 19 dans la
rue enseignant massivement la pétition
intersinicale pour dire que le report de
l'âge légal n'est pas n'est pas n'est
pas juste mais c'est sûrement pas en
menant ce type d'action qu'on a qu'on
aura l'opinion avec nous voilà pour la
mise au point il n'empêche au delà de
ces menaces de coupure les députés de la
majorité sont inquiets oui parce qu'ils
ont tous en mémoire la période des
gilets jaunes rappelez-vous un député
avait été menacé jusque dans son jardin
une députée avait vu ces voitures
personnelles incendiées alors cette fois
évidemment le camp présidentiel Satan au
pire ils en ont parlé ce matin en
réunion de groupe ils ont fait part de
leurs inquiétudes pas question pour
autant de se barricader Aurore berger la
patronne du groupe Renaissance ici à
l'Assemblée appelle ses troupes vous
allez faire de la pédagogie à aller sur
le terrain pour rencontrer les Français
mais certains se demandent bien parmi
les députés comment ils vont pouvoir
organiser ces fameuses réunions
publiques alors la direction du groupe a
annoncé à quelques conseils une forme de
mode d'emploi pour faire en sorte que ça
se passe bien alors ils indiquent à leur
députés qu'il faut toujours prévenir le
préfet encadré évidemment ça sonne tout
le sens que si un ministre vient il faut
en faire la publicité mais pas trop
qu'il faut ne pas renoncer à s'exprimer
bref trouver le bon en même temps pour
ne pas renoncer à convaincre mais
s'organiser
voilà c'est c'est voilà ça fait peur de
se dire qu'on en est arrivé là on va
enchaîner avec vous Vincent Marine Le
Pen est en Afrique au Sénégal en plein
débat sur les retraites ça vous intrigue
et oui Marine Le Pen a choisi de fuir au
Sénégal trois jours durant les frimas de
l'hiver et le bazar annoncé du jeudi qui
vient jour 1 de la rébellion contre la
réforme à chacun sa retraite et bien la
patronne du rassemblement national s'en
offre une au pays de la téran
le cadeau destiné alors à l'icône de la
nation arc-en-ciel un couple de colombes
en cristal de Baccarat d'autres
personnages illustrent aussi ce
compagnonnage
ambiguë
par exemple le maire de Perpignan est
compagnon de Marine l'ancien ministre
congolais Guy brissent parfait collés
puis au FN Bernard Houdain qui fut dans
une vie antérieure secrétaire du groupe
Union défense le guide vous savez cette
phalange est étudiante fascisante sera
ministre de la salubrité publique de
l'Ivoirien Laurent Gbagbo pourtant
socialiste en 2007 on a vu Jany Le Pen
reçu avec les égards dû à l'épouse du
chef au Cameroun et si offrir un
trekking dans un sanctuaire forestier
pygmée et ce en compagnie du sinistre
humoriste Dieudonné antisémite compulsif
et ami de la famille ultime anecdote
Marie-France Bokassa l'une des filles de
feu l'empereur de Centrafrique m'a
confié un jour que son paternel votait
Le Pen lequel confesse en la tendresse
que lui inspirait l'ancien sergent-chef
de l'armée coloniale par ailleurs
Gauliste dévot et on n'est pas à ça près
Jean-Marie l'invitait à dîner lorsque je
cite il était dans la débine et Sa
Majesté Impériale lui avait d'ailleurs
offert une épée de son sacre vous savez
cette piteuse mascara d'Afro
napoléonienne orchestre
Cardy les étapes de la dédiabolisation
de Marine Le Pen passe par l'Afrique
merci pour cette chronique le temps nous
est compté si on a le temps vous
réagirez à ce que vous voulez Clarisse
faire en fin d'émission Delphine ce
petit robot d'intelligence artificielle
son nom c'est chat difficile vous l'avez
passé au crible inquiétant ou
réjouissant on démarre d'abord j'adore
parce que ça permet de montrer à quel
point ce sujet de l'intelligence
artificielle est important pour répondre
à votre question oui c'est passionnant
mais il y a pas de Supra intelligence
derrière on va rappeler quand même que
c'est juste un logiciel qui est là pour
nous permettre de mieux communiquer avec
logiciel rédactionnel qui écrit des
textes quand on lui pose une question
apprends à parler notre langage à nous
les humains qui apprend à le comprendre
déjà et puis à le parler donc à répondre
à nos questions de manière aussi fluide
que possible c'est un chatbot en fait
c'est quelque chose qu'on a tous c'est
déjà expérimenté au moins une fois sur
un site internet par exemple si vous
allez sur le site d'Amélie on vous
propose à n'importe quelle heure du jour
et de la nuit de poser votre question au
petit chatbot c'est à dire à l'assistant
virtuel Amélie Bott fallait que ça c'est
décevant alors ou parce que moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on va pouvoir écrire des
romans avec ce nouveau robot ou faire
les devoirs des enfants non ce qui est
là ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on a
vraiment accès pour la première fois à
je dirais l'état de l'art de ce qui se
fait en matière de chatbot en plus il y
a pas de danger autre que entraîner la
machine à bien nous comprendre et nous
répondre donc c'est vraiment très
ludique on lui pose des questions si
elle se trompe il y a vraiment voilà
c'est pas grave on reformule un petit
peu et hop c'est parti les réponses en
façon instantanées quel que soit la
profondeur des questions qu'on peut lui
poser parfois des questions
existentielles donc il y a un côté un
peu magique comme ça qui peut nous
perturber et nous troubler mais en fait
c'est pas c'est pas plus qu'une machine
à calculer sauf que là elle manipule pas
des chiffres et des mots des phrases
jusqu'à des concepts c'est ça qui le
rend particulièrement pertinent cet
outil mais on rappelle donc c'est un
logiciel il réfléchit pas il a pas
d'avis sur les questions qu'on lui
demande très puissant quand même en
revanche voilà c'est ça qui peut
inquiéter c'est la manière dont on peut
s'en servir et comment ça va nous
transformer les questions que ça pose
dans dans la société si je reprends
l'image de la calculatrice avec mais on
compte plus vite avec des
superordinateurs on va réaliser des
calculs incroyablement complexes et bien
avec ces intelligences
artificielles demain on va pouvoir
décupler encore davantage nos capacités
cognitives donc ça pose plein de
questions
éthiques politiques sociétales
économique aussi les vraies questions en
fait c'est qui va détenir ce pouvoir
entre quelle main vont être c'est super
puissances cognitive
quels états je dirais mais même quelle
limite quelle régulation économique
contrôlera voilà qui contrôle ça c'est
la vraie question parce que ça va pas
rendre les logiciels plus intelligents
que l'homme ça va rendre certains
d'entre nous plus intelligents donc
comment on fait pour partager ce pouvoir
le diffuser le comprendre et le réguler
bah faut se l'approprier il faut
l'utiliser faut jouer avec il faut jouer
avec ça ça vous tente de jouer avec vous
que les trois sujets ont vraiment en
dépit des apparences un point commun
c'est la morale et le droit et la
justice ce que vous avez expliqué tout à
l'heure c'est est-ce que tous les moyens
sont bons pour ce qu'on a défendre ce
que vous aviez dire à l'instant sur
l'intelligence artificielle c'est la
limite de la morale et du droit et puis
évidemment sur l'interrogation de ce
voyage de Marine Le Pen au Sénégal et
toute l'historique que vous avez raconté
moi ce qui m'a surtout et qui a retenu
attention c'est un point commun que j'ai
depuis que je fais ce métier c'est les
gens que l'on rencontre le paradoxe des
gens c'est toujours c'est toujours ça
qui est un art de la synthèse voilà on
voit tout de suite dans les prétoirs
merci à vous les affranchis à vous et
pardon pour le temps merci Stéphanie à
demain très belle soirée documentaire
avec Jean-Pierre Gratien à demain
[Musique]